[Laughter]
Prince William knows a chatty one when
he meets one and he loves it the Prince
of Wales Prince William my understanding
from sources close to the princes but he
is going to have the very key role he
will be heavily involved I think we're
very much seeing King Charles reigning
but with his Heir Apparent and very much
close by on Thursday the Prince of Wales
attended the opening of a new cancer and
Treatment Center in London where he met
a couple sitting in the waiting room
[Laughter]
in the video posted by the Royal Family
Channel the patient's wife could be
heard praising the country's National
Health Service before her husband
interjected with some humor you see
these people here
foreign
[Laughter]
safe to say the patient's sentiments
about William's wife Kate Middleton are
shared globally I think there is a new
confidence about her she is a very
confident poised self-assured woman just
last month Kate looked gorgeous in a
bright blue one shoulder gown to film a
special segment opening the Eurovision
song contest 2023 Grand Final
[Music]
foreign
yeah just days after fulfilling her
royal duties at the king's coronation we
know that Prince William is going to
have a pretty high profile and
significant role not just in the
ceremony itself but the lead up to the
coronation along with the Princess of
Wales
Kate showed off her piano skills inside
Windsor Castle
[Music]
foreign
has been so clever is to create her own
prototype of the Princess of Wales
through the work that she and William do
what Kate's doing is putting her own
stamp onto that title and I think now we
are seeing the seeds that have been sewn
we are seeing the work that she's put 10
years into now coming to fruition and
it's work that really is making a
difference and your wife's not fair
she's an isolated
as for William who is next in line to
the throne he seems to be handling the
job with Grace and Good Humor William
never wanted to leave frog his father he
wants this time to be the Prince of
Wales for which there is no job
description for which he's going to
carve out his own identity whilst
raising this young family these are
precious and important years for him and
he he doesn't want to lose those years
I'll be sat here talking forever